thanks to um the creative and design
thinking program for sponsoring this
session and Sebastian Perry take it away
thanks Robin and thanks Amy
um I'm Perry uh you've got Sebastian
here as well Sebastian's coming from uh
University of Stockholm so he's uh the
Stockholm School of Economics
um we are collaborators at Stanford
um a little bit on our background uh
we're both professors and they always
have these small titles before
professors I'm ad John T's associate it
just it just means we're lower on the
totem pole um here
um that's right probably so and um the
key difference in our collaboration
which is I think comes across in this is
um Sebastian is a researcher and I spend
more of my time uh teaching and running
programs
um so what's awesome is it's this
amazing relationship where Sebastian
will
um we're both Geeks so let's be honest
we're both geek Sebastian um Sebastian
will geeked out and do a huge bunch of
research and has some fascinating stuff
we just watched the video before he's an
amazing experiments and um published
papers on the topic we're getting into
today which is how human beings can
augment themselves using tools like Ai
and with that and then I'll apply them
to classes and we'll compare notes and
um I'd also like to say we love the
questions I already see the questions
um going we'll do our best to to answer
along the way
and um I can't tell you how much we both
appreciated all your questions it drove
a lot of our thinking and
um caused us to adjust the schedule and
actually do this session
um and it's not on demand it really is
in reaction to the inspiration we got
from so many of the questions so with
that we're going to get in because
there's a demo portion we'll see how
that goes we're going to be live on
stage
um and with that let's let's dive in
Sebastian and and show them the overview
for what we're going to go through today
yeah exactly
um
there we are yeah so that's us a brief
recap of the two of us again
um so yeah here's the overview
so we'll we'll do very brief principles
we want to be you know we put a little
bit of effort into responding to the
tenora questions
um we'll spend a time going through a
demo and then we hope that demo will
will stack up a bunch of questions that
allow us to make sure that we take the
concepts we are covering today and be
sure we pull them into your context so
we've we've done our best to pick a demo
that that's true to us we're going to
run something and you'll see and
hopefully
um we will by the end of the hour be
able to make sure that you feel
um confident and curious actually at the
end we're going to survey you at the end
and see if that's true
um to uh we want to inspire you to
experiment with these tools and use them
and understand them
um and dispel some myths today
um speak to a few of these we'll just
popcorn as we go Sebastian this was
based on your your questions from last
time
um yeah yeah so uh hi again
um yeah I mean the as as Harry was
saying uh it was really great to hear
from you your questions uh concerns as
well so we want to do our best to
address those
um in this webinar
um with the with the you know one of the
main messages is that AI will cannot
will not replace you
um but there are many many and there are
a couple of reasons why that is that is
excuse me
so first of all experience right your
own unique experience uh from work life
from uh private life
um and and that's something that's
really hard to I mean like we'll get
into that when it comes to you know
using these tools how to provide context
and that's something that is really
really hard for AI to do um so far
the the second Point here it really is a
is a result of the first point which is
contextualization
um we're gonna show uh show you some
more and some less appropriate
techniques on how to kind of get the AI
chatbot to do what you wanted to do and
so contextualization is is super
important there to to draw on your
unique experiences and perspectives
to to ask the right questions basically
and the next point is agency
um it's really hard to
um get Chachi PT to act on on your
behalf I've been trying a lot I would
love to have an email assistant uh
answer my emails write emails but it's
really really hard because of the
experience that's super relevant to each
and every email uh the context that has
to be provided to uh to write an
effective email that actually answers
the questions and subtleties implied in
the email and also contact specific
aspects like who are you emailing at
what time and for what purpose
the next one is inference which relates
to you know wondering and associating
about a certain topic
um making those creative leaps of course
you know generative AI which is what
we're talking about here large language
models but this includes image
generators a lot of it is considered
creative but what we're talking about
here is you actually suspending this
belief and going in completely unrelated
directions
um so it's a creative tool but it's not
a creative agent in that sense we argued
right Barry so yeah this is these are
key in the in the next one is about
curiosity and I think
um there are some great books on this
these are sort of uniquely
um human characteristics that that are
sort of the perplexed the engineers no
end
um is how to be curious how to be
surprised I mean one of the key aspects
of creativity if you if you look at all
the research but also your livedict
experience is your ability to notice
something be surprised by it and be
intrigued and begin to ask questions
that's you'll see that's that's required
of you given you have a surprise or
you've noticed something we're going to
show you where we have found these tools
are unbelievably valuable for
um for folks to augment their creative
creative process to generate some ideas
and options but the the core
um inference then noticing something
that being surprised the asking a good
question this is this is um thankfully
still a domain of of
um of of us humans um for for quite a
while
yeah and I just have to add here the the
last point is is supposed to say
creativity that was my human error uh
apologies uh so those kind of
inconsistencies that you would see with
human agents but the idea here for
example coming up with an image it took
me quite some time to get that image
generated by by being image Creator
because it would do all kinds of
irrelevant stuff when I asked it to
portray a human being winning over a
robot most of them included the robot
winning over the human so it had no
context and didn't really know what it
was going for there
um but yeah in any case I think those
are some really important things to keep
in mind with the you know headlines
we're seeing nowadays about the AI
takeover but it does have a really
important implications for uh you know
work-life uh employment so I do think
it's important to be mindful of you know
what makes us uniquely human but where
can we accomplish even more and even be
even more creative uh by using these
tools appropriately and responsibly of
course
so this one is I think crucial as well
yeah go ahead it's a it's a great
article and and there's so many things
we can share and Sebastian has actually
been really gracious and that I think
you you've got some sources and in Links
at the end right Sebastian so you're
going to get a bunch of uh yeah that if
you have questions about you know what
do I do if I want to somebody just asks
in the chat what could I use to to use
this for research there's actually a
great specialized tool that's that's in
the in the glossary so I forget if the
questions are awesome and blowing up but
that was one that that's in there or the
hearts came up so so whoever that was
it's it's now buried in the comments but
um that'll be there this is just an
interesting article to think about
something that I Sebastian I really um
share the sentiments of the author here
krakauer who is who runs the Aspen
Institute so a great uh think tank that
deals with super complex problems
um and it the core premise is to think
of AI as a tool
um and there's some tools that we become
very very dependent on as as humans and
it sort of affects our cognitive process
it sort of takes things away the example
used in the article is Maps if you use
maps all the time to navigate in your
digital map and you have your phone out
anytime I go to the market I want to you
know put the map on you'll eventually
maybe lose your mental model of your
neighborhood or you'll lose the mental
model of your city or your your county
or wherever you are in the world because
you're always dependent on it whereas it
it contrasts it with a really
interesting bunch of studies about using
abacuses that as a mathematical tool
actually tend to enhance thinking and
enhance how to structure an equation or
how to think about a math problem
because you have a a new mental model
from the tool you know woodworking tools
things like that there's an analogy
there and we sort of strive to
um in this topic of augmentation and how
to properly augment yourself using these
tools we have found there's places that
these tools are really really valuable
right now and they're not replacing
they're not taking away a cognitive
process there you'll see we put them in
in association with with our own
cognitive creative process
um so it's a fascinating article the
Link's there very short too which is
awesome
um so it's only four pages but a great
one to share with folks and get into
this conversation about where does it
fit and what is what is the use case for
this and frankly other tools I use so
that I'm I'm still have the agency as
the human the Tool's not diminishing my
capacity
yeah because I I think that's a super
important Point um in the in research
including research that I draw on
um for example that by I just want to
acknowledge Eric benjalson at Stanford
uh who has done a lot of research on
automation versus augmentation I think
that really there are different
perspectives of how we leverage
technology and and use technology such
as AI so uh what you were just saying
Perry is emphasizes the importance of
using it in a way that augments us our
human capabilities and helps us
accomplish our human goals rather than
for example replacing us entirely
through automation or even you know
letting the technology uh take over the
primary agency in in various tasks so
again having a human-centered approach
makes much more sense and and no is is
more productive more efficient usually I
would also see in my own research so I
think that's just the point I want to
reiterate and emphasize that's really
the mindset we have about these things
it's about augmentation
if I look down I'm responding to some of
your questions here because we're
getting to them so it's awesome it looks
like some of the stuff in our in our
demos coming up within a couple minutes
here so many of you are asking some
really interesting questions and I'm
taking notes and we'll we'll digress as
we um get to some of these topics in
context
oh that's perfect
um yeah so coming back to con comments
and and questions
um these are as as
um as we've said and communicated we did
an analysis of all the questions and
comments we got from the last from part
one
um uh just to see patterns and and
actually
um you know walk the walk and be data
driven and use AI to help us make sense
of this
um and oh we found you know we conducted
um uh sentiment analysis so what kind of
sentiment was expressed in the comments
and questions and topic modeling so what
topics were most prominent and keyboard
analysis uh along with you know using
tat GPT actually to analyze uh the
comments and and look at what were the
most pressing issues and what were
people most interested in seeing um so
here just just for the sake of
illustration you can see the keywords
here it's about use using it uh which
tools to use do we use how do the tools
work
um uh how can they help me with my
research and my ideas and also at the
bottom there in the survey you see
business learning uh better so we we
picked up on a lot on you know the
Practical aspects which has really
informed our thinking and how we set up
this this second webinar
um and here in the words of uh TPT uh
four
um the next webinar
our conclusion was that we were going to
focus on the spelling myths clarifying
misconceptions uh being even more
interactive and exploratory and also
include Hands-On exercises and provide
actionable knowledge so that's our
ambition right very that's our ambition
for today's uh webinar yeah and I think
we appreciated the comments and I'll
responded by um
the
um just anxiety and the questions had a
balance of emotion that that we took
from it and was noticed even in the
sentiment analysis as we ran it and it
inspired us and I I want to call out you
know Rob and Amy and Tim for being
willing to Pivot and sort of come back
and say let's let's thing again that
sort of
has hopefully
um we we don't expect to dispel you know
sort of um all anxiety and make this all
great but but try to do a better job of
just not breezing through things so
quickly that I think we left a lot of
people asking questions like will it
replace me will it affect my job
dramatically
um if so how help me understand these
things and we wanted to sort of pause
and go this is
um these are amazing tools and respect
those comments and sort of go a little
slower this time and run through things
a little more detail
yeah absolutely right great so
I think
um it's about time to get started right
yeah let's do it with the with the more
Hands-On the Practical aspects as
promised
um so let's let's get started with
prompting uh well first of all what is
prompting uh prompts are the
instructions you provide the chat box
with oh it can be chat GPT Bing Google
bard but prompting is your way of
interacting with in a chat box and it's
um prompting is an ing word on purpose
it's not a single prompt this is the one
of the things we get from students is
you know I I tried to use you know chat
GPT a couple you're asking about sort of
policies and procedures and I think
we'll we'll talk about that you know we
always ask our students to be clear that
anytime they've used
um AI they just need to be clear when
they're submitting something I used it
and I'm responsible for the sources and
responsible for the content the content
is mine it's not I can't blame some
something else a tool I used so that's
just a digression on a bunch of
questions that were coming up in chat
and one of the things I see Sebastian
over and over I know you do as well
um is um our students tend to ask a
single question get a single answer and
say well that wasn't that valuable and
somebody was asking about you know I can
ask chat GPT you know who is Joe Biden
or who is this question and you'll get
one answer and the answer might be good
for your purposes
um prompting is an interaction you're
going back and forth back and forth and
we have a world-class expert in
Sebastian in all of his research so he's
going to run through the prompting and
show us how we actually have an
interaction that that we will play out
publicly about some work on a class and
how it can be helpful to do that and how
um it takes
um effort and prompting is a multiple
interaction effort to get to
um some effective content
that's that's right exactly and no I
think you you captured really well so so
just to expand a little on on the points
you raised there it's all about
the prompting I would say one of the
most
I I guess I'm getting ahead of myself a
little bit but uh an important thing to
keep in mind that that it's not a
database it's not going to provide you
with one-to-one answers that are
accurate necessarily in response to the
questions you ask or the prompts that
you use
um but to just come back to the first
bullet point here
um I would say low effort or inadequate
prompts are going to get you subpar
results so the quality of answers to a
very large extent uh is it depends on
appropriate use in appropriate context
but also the quality of the prompts that
you submit and so what are quality
prompts is an obvious question well one
of them one aspect is to actually
iterate and provide more context and
Clarity to convey your intentions to the
chatbot to help it understand where
you're coming from because a lot of that
relies on intangible knowledge and you
know contextualization as we talked
about before some something that we
humans are still I would say uniquely
able to do so helping it along along the
way
um some other you know approaches that
are useful are the ones we covered in
the first part of this webinar Series so
interactive prompting I just mentioned
cross-domain to help come up with
Innovative unexpected solutions to
problems and also contrarian prompting
to just help uh know the generative
aspects of this creative technology to
come up with new suggestions and that
means that you're going to have to to
iterate and put in the work to actually
convey you know to explain what it is
you want to accomplish and tell it for
example hey paragraph two or idea number
three in the bullet points list was
great no tell me more about that so
putting in the work actually another uh
technique which is very simple
practically speaking is Chain of Thought
prompting so these tools are generative
they are not databases they do not rely
on a formal logic so help it become more
logical uh something you can do by using
Chain of Thought prompting so it's as
easy as using the term take it step by
step step or let's take this step by
step then you force it to reason more in
a more elaborate way and that often
helps for example uh
you know in terms of transparency and
how reasons quote unquote or how it
comes up with solutions to your problems
the second aspect we already mentioned
now a couple of times but it's one of
the most common mistakes I see in
practice in among students among
Executives it's not a database it's not
a tool for you to look up facts or
references or definitions whenever you
get those things you need to double
check them yourself this is more about
the generation about of ideas it
generates language that is coherent and
compelling but that's not the same thing
as generating truth or facts and that
distinction is super important to enable
appropriate use cases so I realize I'm
repeating myself but I think this is
just such a crucial point to keep in
mind when you use these tools it's not
Google it's not Wikipedia it's not a
database it's a creative tool and that's
why we focus on the creative aspects
and lastly
as a result of these first two points it
works best for topics you are familiar
with which in practice I see people
using it a lot for domains or questions
whether or not very knowledgeable and
actually I find it more useful myself in
my own topics of research and and
helping me construct seminars because I
can evaluate the output better and I can
actually
elicit better responses I can craft
better prompts and I can also spot when
it makes mistakes because I know that
that certain reference does not exist so
if I forget to be critical then that
reminds me that okay that makes no sense
because research has this or that
conclusion or come up with these results
so actually it's a better decision
support tool for you in the domains you
know best
so I think those are some super
important uh principles to keep in mind
so in terms of more concrete techniques
we we were just talking about prompt
engineering which refers to the practice
of crafting better prompts to provide AI
chat Bots with better instructions uh
for it to help you better
so we will be engaging in prompt
engineering together in just a minute or
two the secondly here
as we mentioned again being clearance
clear and specific about your requests
is such a crucial part of prompt
engineering you need to provide it with
context background information examples
uh to help break down complex questions
again here
um
so one thing Sebastian is being clear
and that's trial and error meaning
neither one of us that are using this
all the time and we'll actually show
there's a couple of that cool example of
you comparing two articles which we'll
show in your history a couple questions
came up about different use cases
um you'll see that this even for us and
we've we've got together and we we did a
bunch of practices and you know shared
screens and did all this stuff
we had trouble I mean sometimes it's
three prompts and we're kind of wow I've
got something useful for this particular
challenge I was having you know writing
something and I've got some useful
materials sometimes I have to step away
and come back it's just like the Creator
I find it very much mimics creative
process come back a day or two later and
pick it up again and say I just was
asking questions that didn't get
anywhere
um and didn't get useful output it's
it's all it's like brainstorming I could
sit down with um Sebastian or one of you
all and say I want to brainstorm a bunch
of topics for titles for a lecture I'm
giving
we don't have a good brainstorm you walk
away just we don't we're not asking the
right questions you know the right
prompts we don't know right how might we
question about brainstorming and it's
very similar so you'll see us sort of
hopefully stumble a bit
um you know maybe you're gonna be in the
Q a giving us a couple ideas about the
ways to promise but it's it's multiple
efforts it's not a one and done or you
get good at it and you ask three
questions and you've always got an
answer that's that's not the expectation
we want to leave you with
absolutely absolutely
um and yeah yeah again coming back to
you know principles you're just saying
this uh you were emphasizing this exact
point of experimenting uh trying
different prompt structures seeing what
works so there's an intuition there's an
art to to prompt engineering as well
here that you simply you know for for
all the prompt engineering uh tips or
secret guides you might find on the
internet uh there really is no no secret
sauce I think it's useful to use these
rely on these principles but then it's
about you know boldly experimenting and
trying ideas trying your craziest ideas
and to to come up with new ways and new
Solutions and just basically
interviewing it as you would interview a
colleague or a client or someone else
and then again the same thing goes there
um you need to be clear and you need to
ask really good questions so it's a new
kind of challenge it's a new kind of
skill working with these tools which
will enable uh you to you know remain
competitive
um and using these tools is just a
matter of uh training and experimenting
and I guess that's one of the takeaways
that we want to convey today
okay
um
so I think are we ready to uh
umt
ree with that
um let's do a quick tour so explain what
folks yeah
yeah so I'm logged in to my account uh
here on openai's chat GPT interface as
you can see here I have a Plus
subscription which means that I access
to different models I have priorities
a couple less like how do you get there
how do you get to chat gbt how do you
get to open AI you could you could
Google it and you'll go to
create an account and you can create an
account chat chat gpt4 you pay for the
chat qbt3 is is um open
yeah that's it so so just um to make
this relatable I'm I we were thinking
most of you are probably using 3.5 uh
the free version so that's one we'll
we'll use for for now maybe we'll switch
over for GPT for for the sake
illustration but we'll stick with 3.5
for now
and here is a history my own history and
actually this is
um you made a good point Perry before
this is a great uh knowledge report
repository for me to go back to my own
uh my chat history and the results and
outputs that I've submitted and and I
actually do I I didn't even reflect on
that but this is something I I go back
and and check uh regularly
um when I when I'm because the same kind
of challenges keep reappearing or
popping up and and then this is a great
reference so this is my chat history
basically and here you see the model
that's chosen so this one as it says
here is the uh fastest model uh great
for most everyday tasks and that's the
one we'll be using for now
so then we got a question we'll do a two
first we got a question and this will
also demonstrate what is what is here on
the left and how you might use it so one
was a couple of people ask is is chat
gbt something I could use to compare say
two articles
um and help me understand the
similarities and differences so do you
want to pull up I was we were perusing
your past
um
uh sessions do you want to pull up that
one where you compared two articles
yeah absolutely
um so it was actually uh this was for a
task I had just recently
um uh where I was asked to write up a
book recommendation
um
and here I was uh I was kind of
struggling to get started
um so I I used chat GPT to help me with
this
um so let me see here I think it was the
first this one I used to integrate uh
the old the two book recommendations I
got so if you give me a second I'm just
gonna fight here it is
the original conversation
yes so
here for the book review and book
recommendation article
um I think it's going to pop up in in
just a second I ask it here to because I
decided on which two books I wanted to
recommend and then my prompt here is
compare and contrast what these two
books have to say about Ai and how to
make good decisions
um hi Sebastian one thing Sebastian this
is Robin so we're seeing a screen right
now that is your empty chat GPT prompt
says at the bottom we can see your
history on the left so we're not seeing
any of this okay good thanks for uh
letting me know I think it's I'll I'll
just stop sharing and re-share again so
hopefully it uh it shows you uh what I'm
seeing so yeah let's try that out we can
work through it
there we go perfect
okay thanks
yeah so again I'm asking you here to
compare and contrast these two what
these two books have to say
um so I picked Noise by Danny kahnemann
and colleagues and I picked how to stay
Smart in a smart World by great Giga
answers they have they have a very
contrasting perspective on human
rationality uh and you know one one of
them emphasizes how biased we are and
the other one emphasizes that well our
intuition can actually be useful and
they derive different conclusions uh and
talk about algorithms and AI in very
different ways so I wanted to jointly
recommend them to get different
perspectives and here it provides me
with just that an article uh an outline
which is generic
um it's not the way I would write it and
it's a bit superficial but it's a
starting point
and this helped me actually very quickly
get started and what I did in the next
step here is that I used another version
from a previous conversation on the left
you'll see it just the further down
there I used it to integrate
the two versions and write an even
better
recommendation article and then I
further refined it so that's just a very
you know simple example of how I how you
can use it yeah so it's and it goes to
the two sides of We're Not Gonna really
cover today we're gonna we're gonna go
to the prompting and I don't know um
Sebastian my you might have to do after
each prompt reshare if it's not Dynamic
your screen but um the the key here and
you folks were asking about this is it
is a really amazing thing to compare and
that's another area that we could um get
into and maybe do another session is
like it's it the two uses we teach a lot
around are for example what we did with
um questions from the last sessions
because we had so many we we helped AI
helped us Analyze That and look for
patterns and look for things maybe that
we didn't notice
great use case this is a great use case
the other thing is just the usability of
chat GPT and it shows you even how
prompting happens
um or or these sessions can happen over
many many days so this is a repository
on the side and you've got all these
past
um uh inquiries you've done and then you
can go back and even use and and cut and
paste and we'll we'll show you how it
works in a single session but let's go
ahead and um that maybe answers a few a
few folks were asking about that one
thing works yeah sorry I I just saw a
comment here as well by
um Melissa when asking chatipiti to
review two articles
um is it beneficial to assume that it
has already read quote unquote the
content that's a great question
um so what I'm doing here
um is that I actually paste most of the
article uh article that I had from the
previous step or I would paste you know
a synopsis or a summary of the book if
it's an older book before then it would
probably have access to the contents or
at least content contest con reviews of
of the book from previously from the
internet but if it's a very recent book
chatipiti will not have that in its
training data so then I actually
provided with excerpt or or relevant
content or as someone else was asking
you know you can use for example Bing AI
or you can use a chat GPT with browsing
internet access and then it can actually
get that information itself relating to
the book and what it's about but here I
I do what I usually do is I simply paste
relevant information in the actual as a
part of the prompt
yep
right so and and here I think I also
wanted to just show show you here I
start this prompt uh coming back to the
iteration aspect I I prompted here to
rewrite more stringently incorporate the
following background illustrating the
extent to their disagreements
and that's part of this very long
um iteration iterative process where I
where I work with with chat GPT so I
kind of become an editor in in how I
work with chat GPT yeah and how do you a
bunch of questions are coming up and
then let's get to our so maybe as I I
pose this to you
um go ahead and get ready for the
session where we're going to do the
inner like our um our interactive
prompting
um
how do you cite references so what do
you do so now you've got say you've got
some summary and there's a summary
paragraph in there and you're not sure
whether to cite it or not what do you do
yeah so um when citing in terms of
um yeah
if they could be one of these sentences
is an actual quote from the it's not a
summary based on a bunch of different
comments that's maybe
in the public domain some concern that I
this is a great paragraph I want to
literally drop it into a slide and use
it
you know I I personally have the
students do some of the same things
they've always done
which is you know
um check that paragraph for
um for references
yep but how do you how do you go about
that so is the question like what what
happens you copy and paste that into
something else are you or are you using
the question is sorry the question is
are you asking the chat gbt is this you
know
um an appropriate use of these materials
or can you cite anything or do you use
another resource to do that
yeah okay great question
um there's a couple of different ways I
would answer it so
um for students I I strongly you know
urge them to be transparent about
everything they do
um and then
another issue is I don't think we use
the term hallucinations but Chachi PT
can or other large language models are
prone to hallucination meaning that they
make things up
um as we were talking about before it's
not a fact generator it generates
language and language that is coherent
happens to you know coincide with facts
most of the time but not all the time so
that's why you have to be very Vigilant
now you use the tool and that means that
you can get you know inaccurate
information so you should have an idea
of what the books are about I mean I
know the books well uh but you're
writing using using this to write about
books I I don't know about very well I I
wouldn't really feel confident doing
that
um another aspect to avoid plagiarism is
that you know I naturally I kind of put
the final touches
on the article you know myself obviously
I rewrite it in a style uh that I feel
resonates with the audience and is
natural for me because I want it to be
my article and then lastly I think if
if you're using a model that's connected
to the internet I don't know if you can
if my screen is still frozen oh it looks
like it is frozen so but if you go to
so let's run through the demo of you
creating an email and how you might use
it and then we'll go and a lot of you
are asking questions about where's the
source data you know can we get on the
internet I'm doing my best to respond
and say well we want I wanted to answer
some of those questions in context
because that example of comparison and
we're not covering the ai's ability to
compare it to Fabulous use cases that
was with a twofer and also a few of you
are asking about the basically like what
is it where is it how do I get on fgbt
some really uh basic questions and
didn't want to sort of fly by
um hey we're in chat gpg well I don't
know how to get on so things like that
but what's going to happen is
um uh Sebastian has a class coming up in
the fall
um and he has a new topic for that class
and
um uh legitimately we were just having
this conversation uh if you wanted to um
ask for some help from colleagues
including me so
um I said hey give me more information
so this is this is real this is live
um he needs to write me a note I can
think about you know we're both busy
with the end of our school years you
know and asynchronously think about what
he's up to and he's got to write me a
note so this would be an email that he'd
sit down and how long would you spend
preparing an email like that
a while you know you're super busy
you've got a lot going on
so it's then take it away and and just
maybe verbalize what you're what you're
up to and your screen's not running so
we're seeing it run live so
read out the prompt you gave it
okay wonderful yeah so uh here I'm just
starting very simply by saying I'm
writing an email to a colleague
um I wanted to help me with a course in
the fall help me write in the email to
get him to help me with the course
um so that's a very generic basic way of
asking so here you see it spits out
a long email
um and
here it has some placeholders for me to
fill in area one two three and it's just
basically and also placeholder here
course name that I would fill in
um so this one is and placeholder for
Perry's name so here you see already how
how much context is left out uh it
doesn't really know what I want and it's
too long as well so then I would start
iterating right
um so I would go ahead and drop
questions if you got them along the way
or contributions
sorry sorry what's that
I'm just saying for folks in the public
like if you have contributions or
questions you know probably the q a i I
can see that live as uh
so now I'm saying uh that my colleague's
name is Perry the course is about
entrepreneurship and use of AI
to enable augmentation
I am thinking about
calling it
the augmented entrepreneur
and make the email shorter
so let's see what that does
so it's still too long so I'm going to
have to specify probably that it should
only be two paragraphs because I don't
think Perry has time to read the whole
thing
from your creative process now what are
you what are you getting from this so
let's let's sort of break it down you're
you're trying to um communicate with a
colleague you have a complex topic
um there's a lot going on so
what do you
um even just just verbalize what goes on
in your head as you see these
contributions the um ai's making
right
um so here for example it says no focus
is on the introduce section of
Entrepreneurship and AI enabled
augmentation given your expertise in the
field so now it's already you know
helping me or reminding me that I should
actually emphasize why am I asking for
Perry's help with this
um and I would appreciate your
assistance and mentorship which is also
very appropriate uh because I'm looking
to you know get parries no valuable
insights and help when it comes to
entrepreneurship aspects and how digital
technology fits into that
and uh no again here it goes on saying
as an accomplished professional in
entrepreneurship so it kind of knows
already uh you know that your uh very
knowledgeable in entrepreneurship so I'm
probably gonna need to you know
emphasize those aspects and then here it
comes it gets very concrete on in what
I'm actually asking so that's also
another and it's prompting me to be more
specific
yeah so what do you so what does that
drive your thinking like are you getting
clearer your cognitive process creative
processes it's becoming it strikes me as
um I want to put words in your mouth but
verify this or not you're becoming clear
what is the email gonna do and not gonna
do
so you maybe are making a decision now
wait they'd be asking Perry about the
details or should I be asking him about
these things now
um it's your job is you know prompting
and I as the clock goes
um you're you spent maybe minus our
yammering you know two minutes on this
and you're you're sort of sorting out
you're thinking about what the email's
about even is what I would say
yeah that's that's that's true because
I'm it's a blank canvas when I'm
starting I I don't have any particular
thoughts as to what how exactly I should
craft the email so it's an exploration
basically together with chat TPT to to
take these shortcuts that you're that
you're mentioning that's how I would you
know try to describe it basically
so now where does your prompting take
you in the next stage yeah what do you
what are you seeking to accomplish with
this body of work now
um so now I'm trying to be basically
what the things that I took away from
the last round the last version is to be
more concrete uh emphasize
why I'm turning to you for help
and also be trying to say what what is
it specifically I'm I'm uh asking for
and now I shortened it to to these three
paragraphs I actually asked for two
paragraphs I got three but no it's
getting there
uh and here it's about the integration
and it's saying that
you know deeply I'm it's putting here
this one is actually putting what's in
my mouth I'm deeply passionate about
entrepreneurship so I think I guess
guess that's compelling
um and excited to delve into the
practical application that's something
because
I mentioned here that you're very
knowledgeable in entrepreneurship and
working with entrepreneurs and
Executives so here it's again
emphasizing the also the practitioner
side which I do actually want to
incorporate in the course but I I don't
think that's something that would have
occurred to me right away
yeah
all right so yeah kind of a crude yeah
it's provoking your thinking it's
helping you clarify what it's about and
it's um uh you know what I've found is
um so we have students preparing in the
accelerator launch pad preparing pitches
for example and they'll put in
components of their pitches how am I
going to talk about a go to market
strategy for my business like they'll
give a brief background on the business
and say you know how might I explain
this in three bullets
um at some point they take this and they
move to another medium so
um what I what I
um I don't think Sebastian at least I'm
I think I always feel the sense that
your emails are ultimately written um
written by you
um you'll ultimately take components of
this and begin to rework it in your
Gmail or whatever email server you know
you'll you'll you'll author it yourself
using components or ideas from the
session you know or you'll find out
things you didn't that you won't do in
your your
um uh actual email to me
one question is we're getting a lot of
questions you know where does the
information go so let's say you put in
um a lot of information about your class
that's
um you know some of it's in public
domain right so it's not such a concern
is I don't really doesn't matter it's on
the
um this the school I work for it's on
the website so if I wanted to reference
some of that material that's already out
there being scraped by Google and other
people
um but let's say you had a really new
brand new idea you know for what was
going to happen in this class or a
particular exercise you wanted to do or
something you were getting into some
details what happens to information you
put into
um uh chat gbt or Nai in your prompting
where what happens is it now public
domain what happens to it right
yeah so that's also here just I I think
my screen froze I was just showing how
to uh invoke some step-by-step reasoning
by to make it more compelling yeah so
here the what the this goes to open AI
the the prompts and the responses go to
the organization openai who developed uh
or are developing a GPT and chat GPT and
they use it I would assume uh for
further training and refinement of the
models
um so that's why there have been stories
about you know employees uh companies uh
leaking or uh inadvertently disclosing
secret information confidential
information in these chat Bots
um so that's why it it does make sense
to to keep this in mind
um I there are there is a setting I
think it's for the plus plan where you
can make your chat history or the the
prompts that you you can disable chat
history in training temporarily but I
would still be cautious right
yeah so what you put in like the
question is coming up like what you do
put in is it's you're you're putting it
out there and the AI is going to use
that to give other people better answers
and amalgamate it and goes to the
challenge of primary sources and a few
of you are asking what are our policies
I actually give Sebastian credit for
this which is you know my new policy
from Sebastian and from his class and um
the school he works at is
um being clear that students now cite
all of the tools they use so if they're
using uh chat GPT I just asked they say
they use Chachi PT a bit in preparing
this um if they used figma I ask that
they cite they use figma which is a no
code
um uh graphic building so they build
prototypes with that of of apps and
whatnot
um and it seems kind of silly that I
just didn't do that before because it's
a it's great for me to learn what are
they using what questions they have what
what are the latest
um uh techniques you know they're
they're as they put together their work
and then taking responsibility for
um what has your name on it you
ultimately have a responsibility for
figuring out if there's a primary source
that needs to be cited
um if something like that and you can
use you know there's a few folks and in
the Q a that have been posting questions
that have suggestions of of resources
and there's there's some things at the
end of the
um the presentation that you'll have
um that thanks to largely the work
Sebastian did in one of his classes that
are great resources for this kind of
thing
um yeah hey I wanted to pause for a
second because there's been a um I don't
want to
um skip this question
um a few people early on commented
there's been
um you know Sam Altman's comments to the
uh to Congress in the United States
alarmist comments about the future of AI
it must be regulated we you know uh we
we need a little bit of supervision this
is this is potentially
um dangerous as a develops technology in
the future
um how do you how do you think about
that Sebastian I think you've got more
experience with the technology and the
current state of it and also the
research happening that I do
but they're they're asking about these
alarmist comments relative to we're sort
of saying hey use these tools at the to
be creative in these particular use
cases why don't you back up a step and
address what are the comments getting
made and how does it relate to where the
technology is today
yeah I I I think the uh the the exercise
we just did shows just how much manual
work is involved when it comes to
complex communication between human
beings uh also these uniquely human
traits we talked about I think shows
that the top technology still has some
ways to go but that doesn't mean that
it's not something that should be taken
very very seriously because we're seeing
exponential increases in the
capabilities that these models have uh
but just from a everyday practical
perspective uh the the focus you know in
my work has largely revolved around how
do we as employees as uh business people
as researchers adapt because that's the
history of you know information
technology and technology in general it
changes work and how we collaborate and
and so I think that's just something to
keep in mind about how do I adapt and
how do I learn to leverage these I mean
there's a saying you know that no it's
not going to replace you but someone
with chatipity might replace you so
yeah I and I think there's there's a few
questions like that like it's it's right
you know one thing one individual saying
it's frightening if your colleagues are
using chat gbt and you're not and maybe
you know you need to catch up and I'd
say
um we feel passionate about
um equipping our students
um to be productive and pursue the
interest they have and um have a great
career in any field and Sebastian I do
do share that it's really important that
they they learn about these tools and
um we're transparent about learning
about things like citing sources you
know we're I'm I'm chatting with
um Sebastian about what should my well
like I need to have a policy I need to
actually you know talk about this and
um and have a working policy for my
class
Sebastian was really helpful and help
with that so these conversations are
ongoing and at the core we do feel and
the reason we we came back on and did
this is we really want all of you to
feel comfortable
um exploring this and understand how to
use it um and the ways that we've seen
it be really really effective and have
some great results for unleashing
creativity you could flip around our
demo and Sebastian could have done a
nefarious email
um trying to get me to you know
um wire him money you know or whatever
I'm being facetious but he could have
done something that was was about you
know something that's not ethical and he
could have had media helpful with that
it's the the computer doesn't know the
difference
um we chose an example that's that's
really something sincere and an example
of something that's
um allows
um Sebastian in this case to augment
himself he deeply cares about this class
and fall he deeply cares about having
good collaborators and he deeply cares
about writing a thoughtful email to them
me amongst other colleagues he's going
to recruit for this and he's really busy
he doesn't want to miss something he's
he wants to write a good email that's
thoughtful and using this as a as a tool
to generate options
um is is the key message of this
um not as an answer not as hey do my
emails to these five colleagues and you
know send them on my behalf
um one other question and this this
example demo doesn't quite lend itself
um to you but let's say on that first
demo when you were comparing I forget
the two books noise the Danny Kahneman
book and the other book let's say you
made a decision and this will this will
come to a bunch of comments about uh
what has access to the internet what
doesn't you know let's say you said I
wanna I I now I know I want to buy the
Danny Kahneman book noise great I want
to buy it for a class and I'm gonna have
to buy 20 copies
yep
you can the AI you're in right now go
tell you what the prices are and where
to get it cheap could you prompt it or
are there other AIS that have access to
the internet that you want to be using
yeah so I mean the knowledge cut off for
the non-internet browsing enabled
version does not have up-to-date
information and it can check in real
time
so if I ask it now it won't be able to
to say that it will probably speculate
but if I'm using the uh chat Bots with
internet then they can
um
what's what's one with internet access
would that be Bing would have internet
access yeah that would be Bing or for
example it would be this one here I'm
hoping my screen doesn't freeze
um
but you'll you'll eventually get it but
the point here is that you do need to
ask that question a few of you have been
asking I found it it's a great resource
and a couple times we'll get I'll get
data that's a little bit old and
specular is not really useful I'm trying
to quickly get something done and go oh
I'm in the I'm in a AI That's um really
helpful at writing um and really giving
them great ideas but it's not going to
be helpful at a task that I wanted some
help with and
um you know anyway that's food for
thought that came up a bunch
yeah so I think you know time is flying
again I just thought we would give it
one last shot to write you an email that
has some personality so I I prompted it
here to make it shorter one paragraph
add some humor and use my syllabus from
last year so I'm giving it some more
context here this is the syllabus for
the course last year but I'm gonna we're
gonna revamp it completely so here it
says uh help me unlock the Digital
Universe with humor and expertise Hey
Barry hope you're rocking the
entrepreneurial world and reaching out
with a hilarious request for your
mentorship is in the augmented
entrepreneur uh course I aim to achieve
superhuman abilities such as so I think
I don't know if you find this compelling
but um no if you do one might use this
email and send it to you later and hope
you can help me
awesome I can't wait to read it
um
with that I think Robin are we at time
hi we are two we're two minutes out from
time okay so let's let's make sure
before you all leave we did want to
um Amy's got a survey we just wanna we
wanted to get a valence on if this is
making you sort of more confident to use
these tools less confident more anxiety
and feel free to
um give us information and feedback
because we strive to
um we are passionate about
um
helping you
um use these tools and share with you
really our active work and what we're
actively working on right now
um and loving the feedback
um we're up to a hundred and something
questions which is awesome uh and we
read every single one of them so thank
you and we we want the information
yeah yeah same thank you so much thank
you very thank you Sebastian very much I
think what's really interesting is I
think that
um what we're going to see in the future
is people are going to become prompting
Savvy and that's something that's going
to be on your resume that's what it's
going to say it's going to say ability
to prompt for this role and this task
and this thing and it as you said
Sebastian it's about your you'll be you
know AI is not going to make us
irrelevant it's going to be people who
don't use AI so I thought that was I
thought that was very timely and a good
and a good note to finish on everyone in
the audience thanks so much for joining
in all the interaction because it's you
that make these sessions so great
um comparing Sebastian thanks again for
being here and um if you're interested
in more creative content then we've
linked the creativity and design
thinking program in your dashboard and
for everyone here and everyone watching
later we'll be sending out a recording
within one week thanks everybody for
coming and signing off from Stanford